the big Dei con that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now a few weeks ago Americans who
thought conservatives were exaggerating
when they spoke of the poisonous
atmosphere on college campuses
they were finally given a clear glimpse
into the Twisted minds of today's
radical leftists
people like Stanford's diversity equity
and inclusion associate Dean Tyrion
Steinbach
advocacy your opinions from the bench
land as absolute disenfranchisement of
their rights it's uncomfortable to say
that for many people here your work has
caused harm has car has caused harm and
I know that must be uncomfortable to
hear
don't you love it when they snap now
what is the snapping thing all right
anytime judge Kyle Duncan tried to talk
he was the invited guest at Stanford a
gaggle of marxist miscreants begins
screaming and pounding on tables making
it impossible for him to speak
well they didn't want to hear what he
had to say defending the constitution of
course they wanted to make an example of
him it was a warning for other
conservatives who might think of even
coming to campus don't bother
the University's response was
unsurprisingly quite pathetic well they
apologized for the disruption but didn't
punish the entitled brats or Miss angry
pants who also had a hand in stoking the
outburst
now this is because to The Establishment
in Academia business and entertainment
diversity Inc is untouchable
it's just part of the cost of doing
business
and Dei compliance does not come cheap
Tyrion Steinbeck is currently bringing
in a six-figure salary according to the
Washington Free Beacon the maximum
salary for her position is 201 200 now
that's more than most post-doctoral
candidates make and even some tenured
professors
my question is how does this add value
to Stanford my job is to create this
space of belonging for all people in
this institution and this is actually
part of the creation of belonging me and
many people in this Administration do
absolutely believe in free speech
well that's a lie first of all it
doesn't add value because everything she
just said was false the judge could not
give his speech now Stanford is ranked
as the third best university in the
United States it's tuition just went up
by seven percent to 82 406 dollars a
year
now they've been exposed but their story
is repeated Across America in most
academic and professional settings today
diversity Inc is a flim-flam network of
mostly untalented people who figured out
a way to make big bucks from a weak need
business community and of course all
those School administrators
all told they spend billions of dollars
annually to measure and grow their
diversity equity and inclusion
compliance and then train their
employees in so-called Dei speak
workshops include ridiculous cartoonish
presentations and when I say cartoonish
I mean it
let's talk about some tips on
implementing cultural diversity in the
workplace the most important piece to
cultural diversity is that it widens
your talent pool come to think of it
well is Alex a boy or a girl actually
Alex doesn't Define themselves as boy or
girl here are a couple of examples of
what respectfully calling out sounds
like
I need you to stop right there that goes
against our values
it sounds like you're making some
assumptions that aren't supported by
experience or fact they tell us that all
men are created equal despite what is
actually reinforced by everyday
interactions like the classic example of
a white woman who guards her person in
the elevator when a black man enters
okay and they accuse others of
stereotyping the white woman in the
elevator with the black
now everyone knows what this is It's
woke gibberish disguised as a higher
moral Pursuit
but man is it lucrative now we look
through some of the Dei help wanted ads
online now check out what we found
Snapchat is looking for a senior Dei
manager the pay is anywhere from two
hundred and five thousand dollars to 295
000 a year
and for a Dei specialist at the U.S
Federal Reserve System Board of
Governors you could make up to 173 000 a
year
oh and this is a good one UC Berkeley
needs an assistant Vice Chancellor and
Chief of Staff of equity and inclusion
for this you can make up to 279 400 per
year the best part
you can work from home for two days
every week
so even with the economic downturn it
seems like this is a growth industry in
the United States
and this is one we might want to ask
what do most firefighters in Richmond
Virginia make or even young nurses and
doctors in the Bay Area you know people
who actually perform a vital public
service
not as much as the Dei experts I can
tell you that of course they're much
more important
so how does one get a piece of the
diversity and Equity action well you
just need to get your Dei certification
it's fast and it's easy hundreds of
colleges offer many Dei degrees
take for example the University of South
Florida's Moma College of Business
for only 99 bucks and 14 hours of online
indoctrination oh sorry I meant video
instruction you too can get your Dei
certificate
we want to welcome you to this great
diversity equity and inclusion in the
workplace certificate instruction
included emotional intelligence
stereotypes and unconscious bias and
recruitment and retention
participants learn how to perform
organizational assessments and create
detailed plans that focus on inclusive
change and were required to pass a quiz
at the end of each module oh a quiz
sounds rigorous
and when you graduate in Dei you'll get
a diploma stamped with the Dei version
of The Good Housekeeping seal of
approval Isn't that cool
employees who get their Dei certificates
while in the workplace may also get
special consideration by their bosses or
just get the satisfaction that they've
proven the old adage true that there's a
sucker born every minute
of course America's Newfound obsession
with Dei it's an affront to the
principle of equality that we once held
dear
that all men are created equal
yet Dei
institutionalizes bias the idea that all
minorities think one way or that all
nine non-minorities are privileged and
possess implicit biases
and by falling into the Dei trap just
like the ESG trap America also risks
precipitous decline
Dr Adrian Wooldridge speaking to Jordan
Peterson recently noted that countries
that value Talent will end up
economically trouncing those that don't
and further that this will have terrible
consequences for the United States's
geopolitical standing
biggest and most serious challenge to
Western dominance that we've seen ever
which is coming from China China is
becoming more like Singapore and taking
meritocracy much more seriously both in
terms of its educational system in terms
of its University system which is both
highly selective and growing I mean the
way that the Communist Party operates as
if we have America
becoming less meritocratic or less
enthusiastic about meritocracy and China
becoming more meriterocratic or at least
more enthusiastic about meritocracy that
presents the possibility of a future in
which China really pulls ahead of the
United States Dr waldridge makes an
excellent point
gifted and talented programs and schools
are being dismantled and the SATs and
the acts are being made optional on a
lot of colleges creating kind of a new
woke plutocracy of goofballs
how does that make for a stronger better
America
I think that means ultimately the the
American loses and China wins which is
not something I want to see
oh neither do I
so the great pushback against all of
this must begin
the Dei experiment has already failed
look at Biden's cabinet it's first after
first but failure after failure
so we have to go back to the basics
study hard real standards great books
dump the victim studies and gender
bending nonsense equal opportunity for
all equal treatment for all educational
choice for all students across America
breaking the backs of the teachers
unions which are choking off real
educational standards and of course
colorblind admissions everywhere
take economic disadvantage into account
where appropriate then
it's time to go beat China and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else